c'est le début des allergies
saisonnières un mauvais moment à passer
pour des millions de canadiens depuis
les années 80 tous les types d'allergies
sont en hausse dans les pays occidentaux
et une nouvelle étude canadienne ap li
chuck fait un lien entre l'exposition à
la pollution automobile et le risque de
développer des allergies à un très jeune
âge imaginez vous aussi tôt qu'à l'âge
d'un an
bonsoir michel c'est la première fois
qu'une étude arrive à établir ce lien
mais donc mot développerait des
allergies si jeune que ça
absolument on savait que la pollution
thomas automobile avait un impact sur
l'exacerbation des symptômes mais là on
voulait aller beaucoup plus loin on
voulait savoir à quel âge tout cela
commençait alors regardons un peu cette
étude ensemble donc l'étude est cher
c'est une étude canadienne multi-centres
dans l'ouest canadien
près de 2500 enfants on a gardé dix
allergènes commun la sava 10 mythes ou
coquerel en passant par les allergies
alimentaires et celles aidées des
animaux et l'objectif c'est de voir si
on mesure la concentration de dioxyde d
azote donc un polluant atmosphérique des
voitures et les réactions allergiques
est ce qu'on trouvait ce qu'il ya un
lien est bien la découverte c'est que
oui alors plus les enfants reçoivent
deux sont exposés au house oxydes d
azote plus la réaction est allergique
est forte mais il ya des effets
protecteurs céline c'est une bonne
nouvelle si les enfants dont un nom des
animaux de compagnie vont à la garderie
ou un frère ou une soeur mange beaucoup
d'eux de noailles de l'est ça c'est un
effet protecteur pourquoi parce que là
soudainement ils sont exposés et
développent une immunité simple face à
ça et il ya la question du garage
séparer qu'on n'avait pas réfléchi
si vous avez un garage à la maison
coller la maison que vous entrez
j'ouvrais la porte c'est certain que la
pollution va entrer dans la maison
intéressant parce qu'elle a quand même
beaucoup dans notre société
est ce qu'on peut conclure donc la
pollution atmosphérique des voitures
cause les allergies absolument pas c'est
un facteur de risque il faut est claire
là dessus c'est un déclencheur mais ce
que l'étude nous démontre c'est que les
statistiques à eux n'en sont tassées et
lui regardons ça ensemble
serait-ce pour cent des enfants de lune
sont allergiques ont au moins un des dix
allergènes 12 5% aux aliments et 5% aux
allergènes dans l'air font reculer un
peu céline il y a finalement près de 40
ans en 1980 c'était 10 % la population
seulement en l'an 2000 c'était 30% et la
main quelques années ce sera 50 % il ça
commence très jeune un an déjà il faut
dire que l'étude conclut aussi que plus
l'enfant grandit loin justement de toute
cette pollution
oui absolument et mieux il s'emporte oui
absolument les statistiques montrent ça
quand on est loin de cette pollution là
c'est diminue mais ce n'est qu'un
facteur de risque et les allergies c'est
limite un peu d'hérédité beaucoup
d'environnements un mélange de tout ça
il ya plein d'autres acteurs à tenir
compte
c'est assez complète oui beaucoup